hello everyone this next game was
actually played in simultaneous
exhibition by Bobby Fischer it was
played in 1964 in Cleveland Ohio and
Fischer played 52 opponents in this
event and he won 51 games he had no
draws and he also lost one game I wasn't
able to find the game he lost but I
decided to show you one of the games he
won as well he did play before on the
first meal and if any of you know who
this person was and maybe that person is
still alive that wasn't such a long time
ago you know do share in the comments
but let's see this game where Bobby
played before and oh one very nicely in
17 weeks so Bobby Fischer is white and
his opponent is named Jake Walker and
plays b4 and we have E 5 a normal
response by black attacking this before
pawn straight from the start so public
plays Bishop b2 attacking this ePHI pawn
and his opponent decided to play f6 and
let's just stop here for a second but
can't really play nice e6 to defend this
pawn because what we'll simply put b5
and he will kick the night and then win
this pawn but if someone plays this to
you
this b4 and Bishop to b2 ideas simply
playing Knight to f6 and if he captures
this pawn you simply capture the pawn
before and the black is better here you
have 2 developed pieces White has only
one developed piece and you're ready to
castle and well white hasn't really
accomplished anything so if someone
plays this just play Knight to f6 and
then capture and before you'll be just
fine but let's return to the game so
after Bishop to b2 his opponent decided
to defend with f6 so what we played e4
and his opponent captured Bishop
captures and before Fischer develops a
piece Bishop to c4 his favorite spots to
develop this light square bishop - and
we have nice EE 7 and this Knight to e7
is a fine move it prepares d5 and it's
also well if Y plays Queen to h5 check
it can protect with the knight g6 and
well this is exactly what Bobby plays he
plays Queen to h5 check
the well actually black is completely
fine in this position and he has to play
g6 so the Queen has to lose the tempo
and then black simply continues the game
but the black decided not to you know
ruin the pawn structure near the king
and played a knife to g6 and this gives
Fischer all the initiative he needs he
plays f4 now Fischer is threatening f5
and capturing this Knight so we have
each captures on f4 and now Knight to f3
developing another piece so so white
pieces are already developed quite
nicely these bishops are both monsters
we have a Knight to c6 by black and now
Knight to c3 developing another piece
and like decided to capture this night
with the Bishop captures on c3 but we
plays Bishop characters on c3 and well
black this kind of give up his only
active piece with this move and now well
he's left with this pin Knight and he
still can't castle he still can't play
d5 and well this night doesn't really
have anywhere to go
he is preparing to go to e5 but well
we'll get the death but he plays d6 kind
of consolidating e5 and preparing to
develop the light square bishop maybe
he's thinking about playing Queen c7 and
Bishop d6 and even castling queenside
but there's no time for this Bobby plays
Bishop to h4 and now he's threatening to
capture this night here on g6 so we have
a nice night to see 37 protecting this
nice and g6 twice
we have Knight to f5 now threatening to
capture on g7 and if this Bishop
captures the knight and well after pawn
captures the bishop this knight is
pinned and the black will lose a piece
so so after Knight to e5 black decided
to defend the g7 pawn by playing King to
f8 so Bobby Castle this is a very nice
move as it protects his own King and
also puts this rook on a nice a nice F
file
you know x-raying the black king so we
have Queen to d8 guarding that night and
also looking forward to maybe exchanging
Queens but well Bobby plays Bishop
captures on f6 and this isn't really a
bishop sacrifice since the bishop
we captured the database captured and
simply Queen to h6 is instance checkmate
this Bishop is slicing all the way to g8
so after Bishop Bishop captures on f6 we
have Bishop captures on f5 but we played
D captures on f5 now finally attacking
this night we have d5 blocking this
bishop and now F captures on g6 we have
G captures on f6 and Bobby plays Queen -
Queen to h6 check we have King to g8 and
now g7 and in this position J Glover
resigned the game because whatever
whatever black plays here he he loses
the piece it doesn't matter if he
captures the bishop or play something
like Queen to g6 let's see just always
willing to just turn back after g7
sorry about that if black were to
capture the bishop on c4 then simply G
captures mhh with queen king he has the
capture Queen captures on f6 which check
King to g8 and simply rook to e1 this
wins the night here and if if black
doesn't play this if on g7 he plays
something like Queen to g6 well then
simply just capturing the rook with
queening King has to capture
Queen captures Queen H capture screen
and simply Bishop to b3 or e2 or d3
doesn't really matter Fischer wins
apiece and the so his opponent resigned
and yeah like I said Fischer played 62
games he won 51 game and lost one game
and I really want to know which game he
lost and who it was that defeated Bobby
Fischer in that event so if some of you
do know please do share in the comments
yeah that's it that's how Bobby played
this night
nice seventeen million miniature in the
in the Polish opening so called
tartar cover gambit but some people also
call it the Fischer gambit is Fischer
this spoke of it quite a lot so and
that's it that the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and I'll see you
soon